like bright-eyed and you know like I  can't believe you know everything that I  was walking into you mean  but did that begin with rolling stone  when you were you were hanging out yeah  that's really the biggest rock and roll  star that wasn't really my hangout I  know I know come on you were part of the  thing my god I didn't it was a rolling  caravan and you were part of it  I know am I wrong or not it was a  rolling caravan here and you a part of I  went on tour with the Rolling Stones and  I just said me too for two or three  cities owned in 1975 I was the tour  photographer for the Rolling Stones I  hung onto my camera for dear life really  because what it was your security  blanket it was no because it scared the  hell out of me